[Music]
veterans of the falklands war came to
honor the servicemen who died
four decades on memories of the brief
but bitter conflict still haunt those
who were there
the backdrop for the commemoration the
armed forces memorial
lives lost remembered here there's names
on here
of three very good friends of mine names
on a wall that means so much to me bill
haley served in the royal navy
the loss of a close colleague his most
vivid memory i had to put him in a body
bag a very good
close friend
and
when you do something like that you
realize
your
life is very short very quick it can be
over very very quickly
and you just try to carry on and do your
best you can
for the people that are no longer here
it was april 1982 when a task force set
sail from the uk three days after the
argentinian invasion
during weeks of fierce fighting hundreds
were injured
255 british service personnel were
killed
seven british ships were lost and nine
aircraft shot down but as troops
advanced on the capital the argentinians
surrendered
[Music]
to all those who fought for their
freedom
messages from a new generation of
islanders
i'm an islander born and raised and
because these people gave their lives
and fought here
i'm i have my freedom
thank you and we'll always remember you
at the going down of the sun
and in the morning
we will remember them
their sacrifice honored by those who
served alongside them
pride here and sadness for the men they
left behind
becky johnson sky news staffordshire